[Music]
all right let's do this one last time
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new spider-man video for
the mystery movie that Sony just
announced is coming out October 2021 so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the spider-man
videos we're doing a movie ticket
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your best
theory about what the mystery movie is
on the video these will just be my top
10 picks for what I think that movie is
since it seems like Sony is rolling so
hard on bringing Tom Hall and spider-man
into the venom movies Kevin Feige even
confirmed they're doing that eventually
and because of all the scenes from the
Morbius movie in the Morbius trailer
with different versions of spider-man
appearing in Easter eggs it seems like
they're also trying to do some version
of a live-action spider-verse so just to
be clear this mystery October Marvel
spider-man movie is being released by
Sony it's not Marvel Studios but
spider-man 3 with Tom Hall it will be
coming out just a few months before it
July 2021 so you'll have mainstream MCU
spider-man then a couple months later a
Sony venom verse spin-off movie they're
kind of considering all their movies
that they make by themselves spin-offs
of the venom movie starting with number
live-action spider-gwen Sony is
developing spin-offs of the animated
spider-man into the spider burst
characters spider-gwen is one of those
with Hailee Steinfeld's version of the
character from that movie it was also
reported that Sony was interested in
doing a live action version of
spider-gwen at some point the reason why
she's at the bottom of my list though is
because they're a bunch of other female
spider-man characters who Sony already
announced that they're starting scripts
for meaning that they'll come way before
we ever see live-action spider-gwen
number 9 venom 3 also very low on my
list because it's way too soon to do it
direct venom sequel the year after venom
2 if it wasn't clear venom 2 is coming
out this October
they've been stealth making their venom
versus carnage movie for the last couple
of months with Andy Serkis they're
almost done shooting completely they'll
be a venom 2 trailer next month I
haven't done a ton of venom videos
recently but they signed Tom Hardy to a
5 picture deal when he signed on for the
first venom movie so
more about that when I do more venom to
videos but yes of course they're gonna
do venom 3 in addition to a couple other
venom crossover movies with other
characters including Tom Hollands
spider-man but it's low on my list just
because it's way too soon to do a sequel
right after you do another sequel number
8 a live-action Miles Morales spider-man
movie this is also a bit of a
spider-gwen situation the reason why
it's so low on my list is because miles
was already introduced in spider-man
homecoming is a very young kid he's the
nephew of Donald Glover's Aaron Davis
Prowler character just like in the
animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movie and right now I don't
think that Sony wants to do him as a
character Walt um hones spider-man is
still in the middle of building up to a
big venom maximum carnage crossover
story and a sinister six team up movie
and since Marvel introduced him in the
MCU first miles would probably show up
in the MCU before he showed up in a Sony
movie but I think there's some weird
rules about what Marvel is allowed to do
with the character in what Sony is
allowed to do with the character number
7 live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse
they definitely seem like they're
teasing alternate versions of spider-man
from the multiverse with all these Tobey
Maguire's spider-man Easter eggs and the
Morbius trailer and on the set of the
Morbius movie where the scene was
happening the other day but again it's
way too soon to do full-blown
live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse they're animated
spider-verse movie was one of the best
spider-man movies of all time not just
animated movies but one of the best
spider-man movies of any kind including
the live-action movies Amy Pascal was
asked about it last year will you ever
do live-action spider-verse she said the
studio was considering it but they're
currently releasing spider-verse 2 in
2022 so I don't think they're gonna
attempt live-action spider-verse until
after they do sinister 6 in spider-man
vs. venom there's a lot of big
crossovers that Sony wants to make so
spider vs. on the list it's just lower
on the list than some of the other more
obvious choices number 6 there's that
Madame web movie that Sony announced
last year they said that they were
making it so obvious it's gonna happen
at some point the way that Kevin Feige
spoke about Tom Hollands MCU spider-man
crossing over into Sony's venoms
Cinematic Universe made it sound like
he'd be traversing the spider verse in
the same way that the animated
characters did during the spider verse
movie in multiverse travel has to make
sense on some level and
that either Doctor Strange opens a
portal for MCU spider-man to crossover
or someone creates a live-action version
of that multiverse machine the kingpin
made during the animated spider-verse
movie or as they did during the
spider-man comics in the 90s animated
spider-man cartoon series Madame web has
the ability to travel the multiverse or
the spider-verse as you call it and
she's responsible for Tom hall at MCU
spider-man winding up inside the venom
movies that's really complicated though
I have a feeling that when Sony actually
does bring Tom Holland into the venom
movies it's gonna be a way simpler
explanation
number five there's the silk movie in
Jessica drew spider woman couple years
ago Sony announced that they were
developing a silk movie with Cindy moon
and obviously they've been talking about
Spider Woman for a while there was a
version of Cindy moon that actually
appeared during spider-man homecoming
they already did a high school version
of that character in the MCU but she
didn't come back for spider-man far from
home and she wasn't on the bus in
Avengers infinity war for that short
scene or in the Avengers end game ending
scene with spider-man after they all got
snapped back so whenever silk eventually
shows up she'll probably be a totally
different actor someone who's a little
bit older and the reason why this is
lower on my list is because there are a
couple other way more popular female
Spider Man characters that Sony is
making movies for that I think that
they'll do first Jessica drew Spider
Woman is also one of those weird
characters that Marvel has partial
rights to they can do Jessica drew as a
secret agent but they can't do her as
Spider Woman and Sony can do her as
Spider Woman so it's kind of a question
as to who's gonna get that character
first number four a sinister six movie
Amy Pascal pretty much said flat out
last year that they're doing a sinister
six movie involving some of the MCU
spider-man villains we just saw vulture
show up in the more BS trailer that all
kind of makes it sound like Marvel and
Sony are gonna collaborate again for a
Tom Hall on sinister six movie the
reason why this isn't number one though
even though they said that they're
making a sinister six maybe is because
the October mystery movie that we're
talking about in this video is just
gonna be Sony not MCU and you have to
remember that October is typically where
they put their smaller movies that
they're not totally sure gonna blow up
even though venom made a ton of money
sinister six is such a huge idea that
when they do eventually release that
movie it'll
probably beat in the middle of the
summer fourth of July weekend where they
usually put the main spider-man films
number three spider-man vs. venom as I
said Kevin Feige even reported this was
happening last year but it still seems
like it's way too early for that to
happen right after spider-man 3 there
might be some sort of spider-man 3
post-credit scene
teasing venom or Tom Holland traveling
the spider-verse
or something like that but my early
guests a long time ago was that venom 3
would be the first big venom spider-man
crossover movie and they would just do
it as maximum carnage because that's
what it seems like the venom movies are
building up to and that probably won't
happen till at least 2020 to my top two
picks here are the ones that I think are
most likely for this smaller mystery
Sony Marvel October movie so number two
black cat Sony announced a while ago
they were doing a black cast silver
sable team-up movie then decided they
would just do them separately black cat
is probably one of the most popular
female spider-man characters that Marvel
has not shown any interest in doing up
to this point inside the MCU spider-man
movies and Sony has the rights to the
character so she's right to show up
whenever they want then my number one
pick probably the most likely candidate
most of you probably guessed this
already is a Kraven the hunter solo
movie last year Sony hired a writer to
work on a Kraven the hunter movie the
writers spent a bunch of time in
interviews talking about it hyping it up
and with the way the lower budget John
wick movies had become so popular the
last couple of years Sony probably wants
to John wick some of their spider-man
and venom verse side characters like
wait a minute we can do this movie and
we don't have to spend as much money as
we do on the big spider-man movies
Kraven is just one of those characters
that's perfect for a John wick style
hardcore movie and there's also the
recent rumor that Marvel wants to intro
the character inside spider-man 3 but
that's just a rumor so it's totally
possible that they pull a spider-man
Captain America Civil War situation
where he debuts briefly during
spider-man 3 then a couple months after
that he goes on to his solo movie and
gets a much bigger story they did the
exact same thing with spider-man he
shows up in Civil War then a couple
months later they released spider-man
homecoming I don't have a ton of picks
for who I want Kraven the hunter to be
whether he shows up in the MCU or the
Sony movies first Joe Manganiello did
say he really wants to be Kraven and it
would be
to bring it back around to more tobey
maguire spider-man Easter eggs because
Joe Manganiello was Flash Thompson
during the Toby's spider-man movies so
everyone post your theory for what you
think this mystery Sony Marvel movie is
going to be they'll start shooting
spider-man 3 with Tom Holland this
summer around the time Morbius comes out
in theatres in the venom 2 trailer will
probably be released in March next month
it'll be really interesting to see if
Sony does the same thing that they did
with the Morbius trailer and put a whole
bunch of spider-man Easter eggs and
references in venom 2 trailer scenes
congratulations Cameron Morris you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
venom Morbius video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details
everyone click here to watch that new
Avengers infinity saga deleted scene
with Thor and click here for that new
spider-man scene that was happening
inside the Morbius movie in venom -
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome this is the way